i assure you this won't get blown out of
proportion bet enough i asked for a
babysitter was promised you'd have an
iron grip on this situation mayor
sir
we just got results from erin o'connor's
latest biopsy
she's positive for anthrax
her first test was a false negative
because she'd already been on cipro
didn't i already give you what you asked
for we need to do a lot more to close
off one floor
anthrax is here who ran the test cdc
brand new testing method and by new is
that some sort of experimental thing
and
unless you have any new proof that she
got it here at 30 rounds that was a
positive biopsy result not enough riker
take that as a note mayor giuliani the
press is ready for you and assistant
director man is standing by thank you
you gotta understand
a local team is doing everything by the
book
they're good
but they need more to go on
conjecture is the enemy here
you get an attack letter in an evidence
bag and hold it up in front of the
cameras i can get us anything we want we
went through every inch of that mail
room
aaron knows she handed the letter off
then you jumped a step when you retraced
it
the truth is never about what should
have happened
thank you all for coming
i just want to be clear that
we're talking with you today because
we're being overly cautious
all employees as well as areas of the
building that may have been exposed will
be tested we're missing something
we've been through every piece of hate
mail twice
mail room doesn't bag them though do
they
uh no i think security guards collect
potential threats from each floor which
guard handles the mail from nbc
after a
long talk with the cdc the chances that
this is contained very good
that is what do you need pal
fbi
we're looking for a letter that was
addressed to tom brokaw came in a green
plastic bag seen anything like that
nothing
guys could be anywhere here
start over there
while the powder in the letter
proved negative for anthrax
skin biopsy did test positive
and since
this incident could date back as early
as september 25th
there's a decent shot that anyone who
might have been exposed would be by now
that is our hope
i encourage everyone not to overreact
and be seen
in control of the situation in
cooperation with governmental agencies
including cdc and fbi if anyone receives
any suspicious mail the best thing to do
contact the police
or fbi
get out
leave the sandwich
chris
stay back
i'm vaccinated but you need to leave and
get that guy on sit bro
please excuse me mr
told you giuliani exactly how safe is
dirty rock right now
the cdc and the fbi have informed us
that the chances that this is contained
are very good
any connection to 911
i'll let our local assistant director
moan answer that
thank you
uh at this moment we see absolutely zero
link to 9 11.
[Music]
you